messieurs les présidents
monsieur le premier ministre
messieurs les premiers ministres
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
mesdames et messieurs les officiers
généraux
sous-officiers gendarme adjoint
volontaire d'activé ou de réserve
personnel civil de la gendarmerie
nationale chère madame beltrame
chère madame nikolic beltrame
chères familles
mesdames et messieurs il était environ
11 heures ce vendredi 23 mars 2018
lorsque le lieutenant-colonel arnaud
beltrame s'est présenté avec ses hommes
devant la grande surface de trèbes dans
l'aude un quart d'heure seulement leur
avait suffi pour être sur les lieux que
savait-il à ce moment là ni terroristes
qui s'y étaient retranchés
il savait qu'il avait un peu plus tôt tu
es le passager d'un véhicule
jean-michel jean-michel mazières et
grièvement blessé son conducteur
renato gomes da souza qu'il avait fait
feu sur des crs aux abords de leurs
casernes et blessé l'un d'entre eux à
l'épaule le brigadier frédéric poireau
que dans ce commerce où il s'était
retranché
il avait abattu deux hommes à bout
portant
hervé sosna un client et christian
medvès le chef boucher
nous pensons
en cet instant assez blessé à ces morts
no more et à leurs familles dans le
recueillement
il savait aussi que le terroriste
détenez une employée en otage qu'il se
réclamer de cette hydre et islamiste qui
avait déjà tant meurtri notre pays qu à
vis de données en ce meurtrier chercher
la mort chercher sa mort cette marque
d'autres avant lui avaient trouvé une
mort qu'il croyait glorieuse mais qui
était abject une mort qui serait pour
longtemps la honte de sa famille la
honte des siens et de nombre de ses
coreligionnaires une mort lâche obtenu
par l'assassinât d'innocents
l'employé prise en otage était de ces
innocents pour le terroriste qui la
tenait sous la menace de son arme
sa vie ne comptait pas pas plus que
celle des autres victimes
son sort sans doute allait être le même
mais cette vie compter pour arnaud
beltrame elle comptait même plus que
tout
car elle était comme toute vie la source
de sa vocation de servir accepter de
mourir pour que vivent des innocents tel
est le coeur de l'engagement du soldat
être prêt à donner sa vie parce que rien
n'est plus important que la vie d'un
concitoyen
tel est le ressort intime de cette
transcendance qui le porte est là
et et cette grandeur qui a sidéré la
france
le lieutenant colonel beltrame avait
démontré par son parcours exceptionnel
que cette grandeur coulait dans ses
veines elle irradiés de sa personne elle
lui valait l'estiment de ses chefs
l'amitié de ses collègues et
l'admiration de ses hommes à cet instant
toutefois d'autres
même parmi les braves aurait peut-être
transiger ou hésité mais le lieutenant
colonel beltrame s'est trouvé face à la
part la plus profonde est peut-être la
plus mystérieuse de son engagement il a
pris une décision qui n'était pas
seulement celle du sacrifice mais celle
d'abord de la fidélité à soi-même de la
fidélité à ses valeurs de la fidélité à
tout ce qu'il avait toujours été et
voulu être à tous ceux qui le tenait
ce choix lui ressemblait tellement que
sa mère
apprenant qu'un gendarme accomplissez ce
geste a instinctivement presque
charnellement reconnu son fils elle a su
que c'était lui
avant même de savoir lucide
déterminé le lieutenant colonel beltrame
appris auprès du terroriste la place de
l'otage il était un peu moins de 12h
un soldat aussi aguerri gendarmes
d'élite cité au combat en irak santé
sûrement qu'il avait rendez vous avec la
mort mais ils avaient rendez-vous avant
tout et plus encore avec sa vérité
d'homme de soldats de chef ce fut la
source de son immense courage pour ne
pas manquer aux autres il faut ne pas se
manquer à soi même
le lieutenant colonel beltrame a fait ce
choix parce qu'il se serait
éternellement reproché de ne pas l'avoir
fait je sais ce que peuvent ressentir ce
qui était à ses côtés ce jour-là il
revoit s'écouler lentement les minutes
qui ont conduit à cette décision
il revoit le lieutenant colonel beltrame
déposer son arme lever les bras et
s'avancer seul vers le terroriste ils
savent désormais que tout s'est joué là
ils savent aussi qu'ils n'auraient
laissé sa place à personne car l'exemple
vient du chef et l'exemplarité était
pour lui comme pour chacun d'entre vous
une vertu cardinale
au coeur de tout vrai courage se trouve
une grande force morale elle seule elle
ne se discute pas elle pousse à agir
avant même ce 23 mars
le lieutenant colonel beltrame était de
ses fils que la france s'honore de
compter dans ses rangs
l'hommage que la patrie lui rend ce jour
nous le rendons aussi aux actions
remarquables qui avaient jalonné sa
carrière comme elles jalonnent la vie de
tant de ses camarades au sein de nos
armées dès sa sortie de l'école saint
cyr il avait choisi la gendarmerie il en
avait fait sa seconde famille parce
qu'elle était proche de la vie de ses
concitoyens et qu'elle exigeait de lui
chaque jour
l'excellence une gendarmerie qui paient
chaque année son tribut à la sécurité et
à la protection des français
une gendarmerie qui cette fois encore
s'est illustré par sa maîtrise et sa
force et je rends ici hommage aux forces
de gendarmerie de l'aude à leur chef le
colonel sébastien guay au chef du gign
de l'antenne de toulouse et à ses hommes
dont deux ont été blessés
en menant l'assaut
tous sont durement éprouvé par la perte
de leurs camarades
je sais et les français savent qu'ils
ont tout fait pour que le pire
n'advienne pas comme leurs camarades de
la police et du renseignement et de tous
les services de la préfecture
les français n'oublient pas non plus
le tribut payé par toutes nos forces de
sécurité sur le sol national et par nos
armées sur les théâtres extérieurs
tous ont droit à notre respect
inconditionnel et tous je le sais
partage la certitude profonde qui a
animé le lieutenant colonel beltrame
celle que son destin ne lui appartenait
pas tout à fait qu'il avait partie liée
avec quelque chose de plus élevé que lui
même car ils étaient 1 engagés et ils
avaient juré de faire corps avec un
idéal plus grand et plus haut
et cet idéal c'était le service de la
france